die Kita striegistaler Spatzen in
Bräunsdorf bei Zwickau ist das der droht
die Schließung einfach Schluss für 16
Kitakinder weil Strom und Heizung zu
teuer sind
Bildreporter Frank selig war dort am
Abend bei einem krisenelternabend in
dieser Kita der jetzt die Schließung
droht ich grüße dich herzlich heute früh
bei Bild live was genau ist dort in
diesem Elternabend passiert die Eltern
müssen ja alarmiert sein jetzt
ja guten Morgen hier aus Mittelsachsen
ja der Elternabend der war eigentlich so
ein ganz normaler Elternabend zu denen
da eingeladen wurde und gestern Abend
liest dann der Bürgermeister im Internet
auf der Homepage plötzlich die Bombe
platzen die Kita soll geschlossen werden
weil sich die Gemeinde das nicht mal
leisten könnte die es sei wohl Platz für
die Kinder die würden dann auf andere
Einrichtungen verteilt werden aber eben
weil diese Kita nur sehr wenige Kinder
hier und betreut werden soll sie eben
geschlossen werden um Heizkosten zu
sparen von November über die
Wintermonate bis April so zugemacht
werden es wird halt mit Gas geheizt und
die Gemeinde wie gesagt hat nicht so
viel Geld und man hat gedacht man muss
halt überall sparen und jetzt wird halt
hier bei den Kleinsten Versuch zu sparen
viele Eltern waren sehr aufgebracht
natürlich waren sehr emotionale Debatte
die sich dann hier die entfacht wurde
und am Ende wollte er dann aber leider
niemand mit uns vor der Kamera sprechen
der Bürgermeister sagte letztendlich
aber selber sehr emotional sagte ihnen
ist es sehr nahe gegangen aber jetzt
noch mal eine Nacht drüber schlafen ob
das nun wirklich so weit kommt aber die
Eltern zeigen haben so mit uns
gesprochen haben aber kein Verständnis
letztendlich für die Sache weil
letztendlich das ist ja ein Gebäude es
muss natürlich trotzdem über die
Wintermonate geheizt werden weil wenn
man hier die Heizung abstellt kommt
natürlich das Schimmel und deswegen sage
sagten wir uns und muss natürlich
mindestens 16 Grad sein und ob jetzt nur
20 oder 16 das verstehen die Eltern
nicht was das für ein Unterschied macht
hier kommen jetzt die ersten Eltern auch
hin schon bringen ihre Kinder einige
haben uns für uns erzählt für Sie
bedeutet das viel größeren Weg sie
müssen dann ins nächste Gemeinde ja
durchbringen zehn Minuten hin zurück
verstehen das eben nicht ne alle hoffen
jetzt hier dass der Bürgermeister der
sie über Nacht noch mal drüber schlafen
will
dass er vielleicht doch noch das
irgendwie zu retten ist und aber diese
Problem hier in dieser Kita an der
striegisthaler Spatzen hier und sagt das
ist ein bisschen sinnbildlich für
für ganz Deutschland für viele Kommune
die solche Probleme derzeit haben wir
alle von oben kommt der Befehlen ihr
müsst überall sparen und und jetzt
versucht man überall den Rotstift
anzusetzen und ob das noch bei den
Kleinsten hier der richtige Weg ist das
ist eben ein bisschen fraglich natürlich
vor allen Dingen die Krippenkinder bei
16 Grad frieren lassen das erscheint mir
ganz offensichtlich nicht der richtige
Weg danke dir Frank für den Moment